in terms of the level of evidence that
was required to remind them so my
position is that it's unacceptable
reminder for someone when you haven't
got enough evidence to prosecute or to
convict the threshold to hold someone
isn't isn't the way you frame day where
it's very close to basically prosecute
or convict the evidences based on
Reasonable Suspicion so the bar is very
low to meet that threshold hence why I
have a problem with it if the bar was
much higher it was close to a Beyond
reasonable doubt maybe even if it was a
balance of probability we could maybe
talk about that and look at the
possibility of why that would be
acceptable but when the balance is
reasonable suspicion the bar is very low
it's easy to me and that's why I think
so unacceptable